okay so uh this is the second part of
this as I said before this is more
questions than answers
so this gives you another different
perspective how looking at the interior
Point method
so a little bit beyond also uh with iron
gate
so this actually is written by Bento who
is also here
part two okay so the I would say
there was various lotions of solving LP
okay
so one is called the approximation
algorithms I want to get a solution is
almost optimal almost feasible on the
negative part is also very very small
okay it's kind of Epsilon analysis
Epsilon equal to zero
sniper typically in the rear in-flight
motion arithmetical operations for
example Simplex method which we call the
exact algorithms okay as long as you
carry out your intermediate Source
system in any equation exactly you can
solve linear program
there was some other algorithms which is
uh actually dependency on Epson is very
low let's go to poly log one of Epsilon
okay so if a solid method again is the
iterative procedures okay in two point
also belongs to one those kind of thing
okay so if you apply in two point
algorithms you really want to solve a
linear program in very very high
accuracy
usually people do so-called crossover
so at a certain point you identify which
constraint is going to be active which
means inactive then you move to a Color
Solutions and then
so actually many many interior point of
arguments implementation in commercial
solver they have a Final Phase it's
called a crossover
subscribe to finding a color solution
because color solution is more
combinatory or whatever for solving in
the genetic program you really need to
get the Color Solutions
so but also of course we now nowadays
people don't care about uh high accuracy
you can also analyze algorithm to solve
linear programming you don't need to
look one of the Epsilon you only need
one of the salon so many many lotions of
a forced water method gradient
projection you know
all this has come out okay so uh either
on so I'm my
I'm going to emphasize something at the
high and exact algorithms because this
is what the strongly polynomial time
algorithms
comparatory organization you really get
you know you
know object is the computer tolerances
either yes or no
so
improvement over this
polynomial solver for LP as I said uh
and actually strong and yeah it's not uh
which is local and obviously I just
wanted to mention
um yeah if you omit this one of course
this is a build on the Iran Lee and also
uh I think this is more based on using
volumetric Center okay stuff and also
with the faster you know linear Pope the
basis and server stuff okay
so there's also now is that right
Bento you tell me what happens so now
you can reduce this to end to the Omega
versus Omega is like a matrix
modification those magic numbers
I don't know okay this is a theoretical
sense okay uh of course they also have
NM plus M 2.5 is that it's not true okay
yes so this is uh most recent paper and
this okay so all this is operations but
there was local one of our apps
okay so and that's the matrix
multiplication experiment people have oh
way to do this
the nose to minus like a two-point or
something or something
anyway so uh I'm I I uh so this is a
current progress
what I'm aimed is more on those exact
algorithms okay because my last
dream is to see if we can really answer
that question so LP have a strong
polynomial or not any approximation
Hardware does not do it
you have to find exact algorithm that
so to answer that question so let me
just bring some kind of so-called
scanning invariance in LP algorithms
what is the scanning variance take any
positive diagonal matrix
you scale the variable by saying does
not change the program right okay so you
scale your C by D you scale the Ada by D
and also this same thing so you
basically do this kind of things because
these strictly positive so at the basic
solution those positives still positive
those zero still equal to zero
Okay so
algorithms calling scanning variant if
you generate a geometric identical
sequence when applied to p and d and
after scale
so once a scale is after you scale back
and give you the same sequence
there were some Advantage
method to the scale invariant okay
because uh
because you know it
you know maybe maybe have a better half
Escape variant and the algorithm is very
stable so in these seconds Simplex
algorithm is not a scaling environment
so if you scale the problems for example
for cleaning your scale some problems
the problem actually be organized
whatever of course
so you can feel some kind of a scanning
d as a preconditional
person but of course to find is the best
precondition itself is is the hard
problem
for the other programs for example is
called predict the correct algorithms so
this PC developed it is a scanning
environment
this is the due to the Newton method you
can do this kind of things so recall
what is the you know
predictor I already talked about
and a half hour ago so I'm not going to
do this so stand analysis CB4 degrees
mute by a fact of two in square root n
iterations basically yeah another nice
thing about you can prove
this empty y algorithm at the final
stage when they get close
they have so-called quadratic
convergence
I don't know have you known what it
means so so
when you so I I said it's a central pass
converges to this to some points
a very far away our mu K plus 1 equal to
gamma times mu K as I said gamma is some
kind of a fixed content
okay so we call it you can geometrically
decrease mu k
but you can prove
at a certain stage
you can take a new K plus 1 equal to Mu
K Square
a mucase is smaller enough
that's what predict the correct
algorithm can do they proved at the
beginning you only have a geometric
conference
at the end you're actually it will
divide according to these Fashions we
usually call this as a quadratic
convergence
so if you have an algorithm like this
all the way James you only need double
lock one over Epsilon
the reason is because we know at the
final stage
the central part will be very smooth
okay so that's the one way so the
smoothness come from here so so that's
what and also the algorithms scale
invariant
yes question okay yeah
yeah so this is how
that
how to analyze
the central path
in the
past
we come out with different condition
numbers
okay I'm going to list the two of them
okay one is a related also to Simplex
method that a b be a set of index of
column for a
and then let a b those Corners
constituted by a sub B the subparate
associated with the B we assume this
Matrix is linear is is literally
independent so they will be invertible
okay
so
then yeah you don't have to be all
invertible take those invertibles
the condition number Kaaba
a
Kappa by a is a is defined as Ka bar a
equal to Max B such that the ab inverse
a so this is just a matrix move whatever
okay
so you can think about the inverse of a
b against all other way
for example if this number if if this a
is runtime generated this number is
bounded by n or something
okay
but however we have to take maximum all
the possible bases
okay
as you can see this is a scale
environment yeah basically say if you
scale this Matrix we Define among the
scale damage it's not equal to Vapor a
but however to make it scale invalid it
takes all the positive diagonal matrix
finding the infamous ones
okay
so this is uh so this scale invariant
this scale
uh
dependent
so condition number
somehow but another thing is these two
conditions only depend on a
okay
so what about the exactly algorithm
depending on this one okay so this is
introduced by taking and also on some
part still Mamas and mirror in there
terrorist stuff
so here's the series
as I said I departed from those
approximation algorithms
so LP of the form in this standard form
can be solved exactly this is the exact
just like a Simplex method each relation
is use of system equation assume you can
solve that system equation exactly
the final solution
in N 3.5 log
Kaaba Kaiba a steps
these many iterations each iteration
solve a system in any equation
okay
so
first
this iteration complexity
does not depend on B and C
only depends on condition of a
so that means you have algorithms as
long as a is the same
doesn't matter how you construct the B
and C
you can still solve this by this this
number
you can make B and C up it is really bad
okay arbitrating then
crazy numbers it doesn't matter
uh this algorithm poverty rinse the Bell
to you is that you know in the in the
old days avocado which has a has a
favorite right you can solve an Indian
programming with a running time it's
independent of B and C what she did is
he construct a sequence of linear
programming
and we change B and C and we solve the
other problems basically for any linear
programming and you know you you
construct some kind of length of a you
can reconstruct your PC whose lens is
more normal than length of day a matrix
or something then so the overall because
the because the polynomial complex
depend on the L depends on the bit
length of a b and c somehow he reshape
the B and C whose lens is also
proportional to a so then you can solve
that problem the whole lens is only
definitely but in the middle of
Constructor this sequence you need to do
some
some computational work or whatever
first thing you have done that really
computer was the land server a whatever
but it was these algorithms you don't
need to do it
oh yeah it's the single Loop program
s
only depend on the carbide
okay
so
the key technique is the departure from
so-called affine scanning
so the layer that needs to squares
linear system solver
so this algorithm depart from the from
the
standard and linear program problems or
mty algorithms this algorithm actually
is a scale dependent it's not a scale
generator
okay
just depending on how your scale The
Matrix
as I said scaling could be a good thing
I could be embarrassing but it could be
also a good thing if you know some
knowledge you can scale in to make it at
least condition could be making some
data
yeah
so anyway so this is one thing so let me
just what is the basic idea as I said
the basic idea we know was the a fine
scanning okay each time we only have X
we have to you know find the one such
that they not have eggs use a fine
so-called skinny what is this layered
skin is
you don't directly use x i
they divide they have some kind of a
priority
first
they check the solution
the solution may be split into a big
part relatively close
another layer this layer relatively
close in terms of value but it's
substantially different from this one
okay
usually if you have an algorithm
solution like a Clementi or some problem
always have this structure
or you've solve mdp problem
deterministic mdp those variables on the
cycle
have a very big magnitude with discount
some of those not on the cycle
determinist mdps were basically finding
a minimum cycle some some not answer
cycle some on the cycle on the cycle
they have a big layers under that are
not on the cycle they just equal to one
so
so what we're doing is
we're first finding a Mr do a fine
scanning on this one finding what's the
best solution we fixed that so that one
another assigned space is a fixed then
we do a second layers so this whole
processor still like
a fine scanning and still like a scaling
but some scale
have an Infinity some some you have to
do first
one because I'm sure they have a very
good projection first
so automatically take care of this
so
the clear idea is
you can prove the central pass for given
linear programming problems
they have a n-square short curved
segment of lengths only related to this
condition a x Kappa a
relatively smooth
so for those part
reduced from minimal to this mule you
only need this many iterations
okay
the only way for the proof
this sharp curved
turning point or you call the Kink
points
appears normal the N Square Times
for any given linear program
so you can think about the linear
programming is composed as
well relatively Smooth Spot in those
part you can take a
very large step but however forget the
round of this you really need many many
nine segments to do this
okay so that's the type of a which is
complete so normal than n Square
take
not much to get a one quarter point to
take this much and so most of these
computation is tried together around
these colors
okay yes
well y a to the n on the first sentence
organization will happen yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah
so that's why this one comes when you
take a look you are right I missed the
end of it so there was n over here uh so
there is over here you're right thank
you yeah
okay so it's like from here to here
you need this one actually the majority
of this is suspended over again this one
okay then from here to here you get
another one
okay
the algorithm is not a scaling
environment
okay
so the question is
uh the future some of the workers try to
get this scale invariant Improvement
so the original algorithm is dependent
on kPa a log and 3.5
this is a Montero future 2004 they said
oh you don't need to do this you just
use the analysis from these vavases
paper you just directly Analyze This
predict the correct icon you can prove
your algorithms bounded by unsquare
local augmented and n345 and this number
iterations and this condition number now
is kaipa star
which is scale in value I already told
you so this one is the one yeah so this
one this number is always smaller than
this
because the infamous among all the
positive scanning Matrix
if you can scale match arbitrary you got
this one
Epsilon here
yeah so this is basically say in those
piece very piece called you can you can
reduce mu by mu Square basically in that
piece you only need to get a round of
the
sharp attack
by this much you can and square okay
okay so Kappa is raised to make a skinny
invariant okay here's the comes the 20
people okay
uh this is uh I can including
you can solve this
exactly
but n 2.5 log
HEPA star a
which is the smallest one which is K
invalid
so basically they create the scale
environment
which is that you only need the yeah in
a system solve
it's still like a 3.5 but however you
become the scale environment
okay
now the question is
thank you
how good are those numbers
you may receive this if those condition
number bonded by polynomial in n
you're done you saw your answer to the
question
and you find the Australian polynomial
time
okay
well unfortunately
and so far nobody be able to
if you're only based on Central paths
cannot be bounded by polynomial
so in some sense
API
according to this kind of a past
following nature it's very very hard to
turn this into a strong point
so there are examples yes yes yes
okay so
so the quick question now
how curve is the central part
if they only have N squared
okay another thing for the Smooth Spot
if it's not a Smooth Spot condition
number is still very good
then you can because the curve the big
sharp tank can no more than n square is
already put for Central parts
is the relatively smooth part cannot be
coverage still
only depend on
how smooth basically only a lot of
smoothness can result type A
numbers
Okay so
so this is the questions Okay so
so the sharp attain is very hard to
manage it you can you can think of why
they can make a shopping for example you
slide the details or objective then you
make this straight paths for example
sometimes the central part should be for
example you have an objective like it's
almost parallel to this one right
constraints your central bars are almost
like a vertical knife
all now at this point when they get a
very close all these objectives slightly
deteriorated actually it's the only
optimal solution over here so this is
what we call the sharp 10.
and this cannot be applied more than
SquarePants
okay
the central part is also behaving like
like this type of things this also
applied to calamity
so
how many relations over LP exactly
counter condition number be bound to the
polynomials
because the sharp attain is no matter in
square the only left is those relatively
smooth spots can they be entirely
dependent on you
so this is a question unfortunately this
is uh so obviously from the a geometry
you can
connect this to so-called coverage of
the central part
so what's the coverage
as we said oh I changed in a mute new
level it's the same thing parametrated
by brand new
this is a central pass point
okay
so what you can do
you can Define
this number new okay times x derivative
with u s derivative new take product
okay
then you take an integral from initial
new to a finally
let's say from initial 1 to Epsilon
they Define this to be the coverage
basically
if you have essential Parts like this
you basically integral to the coverage
among all these names
is well defined this is the people how
to find a path to be the coverage of the
past
okay
so
it's already proved okay
the iteration of okay
Central Parts based in a program
algorithm from initial view so final
meal
is
almost equal to this coverage divided by
square root beta when beta times is the
neighborhood width
is basically say
so complexity how many iterations need
to implemented the standard in different
algorithms so what's the case is
basically dependent on the coverage
okay beta is some kind of a constant
uh
you can be sure this coverage if you
remember this is number of algorithm is
sponsored by this one
because the interior point of scale
environment so here Chi bar a square a
is that conditional
so basically say what happens is you say
the coverage
the difference is by a strong polynomial
numbers
if you can prove this one is 20
polynomial
then you're done
okay
you can also regrowser represented by
some kind of differential geometry
quantity so this is a group of people
and also using information geometry
so basically everything boils down
it's a coverage of the central path
now you can
so you can say which needed programming
I need to use LPM is polynomial so for
which one is not by
this condition number
okay
of course you you can you don't need to
be computed this condition number
exactly and people say you can
approximate by by uh by any factor that
should be also
if you can prove something
okay
so here's the some things
100 to go from Hydro meal okay and
always inside the neighborhood depends
on this coverage here so this is related
to the coverage and all and also lower
bounds okay uh I think
uh
people now start a constructive example
to make the other coverage up is really
bad
it turned out you can
the courage what you call it Clementi is
dance
is exponential
okay so if you take a log of the
condition actually the original is
double explanation take a look still
expansion
so that says the standard IPM cannot
attend this into Australian Open you do
have instance type of a is double
explanation take a look still
explanation
okay
so so this number constructed many many
cards but there was another one which is
the very recent I don't know irony you
know these people yeah so this paper I
really want to try to analyze the exact
algorithm to see if you compound that
conditional so uh you can construct the
example
is the podium so this example you need a
Constructor so the dimension of the
problem is very very small but you have
to add the explanation number of
constraints
so this is another example which is any
in number of constraints only is
polynomial in the in the dimension of
the polytope but how I will still be
able to prove that stable expansion
whatever condition
I forget was this for other barriers as
well or no this is the only analyzed on
the central path okay yeah there was no
no other bearing
I want to be interesting question so if
you if you can post this paragraph
number still happens to volumetrics
Center problems yeah
so this is called the all based on the
central part which is standard political
Central path
yeah
so this is a lower bound and all these
problems okay
uh
so
so this really want to to solve this
problem okay so basically say another
one which is given by this group of uh
researches and says
they really wanted to then the developed
another different lotions called the
street line IPM complexity the code SLC
so they basically want to see give any
any curve
then the Define a neighborhood
what's the minimum number of nine
segments stay in the neighborhood
and from the MU zero
W1
okay
so
you can imagine because all the
interpret methods they create some kind
of a straight line right with the in
label wood
somehow still close to Central parts
so the question in French within the
neighborhood
what's the smallest number of
piecewise linear functions
you can approximate that cool
still stay close to another curve
so
you count this number
find this number
actually is very closely again related
to the classical in 2.0 hours
okay so so basically say
for any anyone
if you can find a minimum line segment
within the neighborhood of some
neighborhood of the defined
the interior product algorithms
can almost follow that line segment
with no more than n 1.5 times some kind
of for you know Ada actions they
represented by some tightness of the
neighborhood or something
so basically say of course
for linear program if you don't consider
neighborhood you always have a single
line from initial point this is the
optimal solution correct
restricted to be close to some kind of a
path or Central path that's lies about
the convex region right from any given
point you can direct and see what what
you were solution is because now the
strict line is still interface was that
so the question now
in order to finally resolve these
questions
develop a strong point diagram first
you have maybe developed different
notion of a path
maybe a volumetric essential parts or
something I I don't know okay
okay another one is how to define the
neighborhood of the path
because if you have a neighborhood I'll
be the Mind segment will become
smaller
if you arbitrated large
you can always have a single line from
initial point to the Optimal Solutions
so that's the something
which is
Maybe
people you can think about it okay so
every reasonable Traverse this only
numbers okay for example we have this
one so basically again unfortunately
right now the central pass
cannot do the job
I already have a bad examples
okay this is a four exactness analysis
for for like a approximation then it
says from one view I said that we
already have n cubic root so
so this is all basically give lower
bound
so how good the API
so
let me summarize which problem
are
surrounding polynomial software now
okay
so so far we pasted on analyzed
condition number or you put Simplex math
can do the job
unfortunately we cannot say claim or so
you know this is still sales May opposed
to this question right
Century math question whatever
so
it's funny polynomial known before 2002
shot his past it can be formula as LP
it's comparatory government is the
exponent those kind of of course that's
24 bones
uh by part of the matching and
the already probably also a lot of this
is maximum flow and all this minimum
cost of flow and minimum commodity flow
not as political but I don't know
so
some of this algorithm actually have a
specialized diagrams
okay may not be proved by interior
algorithms
so
this is another picture some of those
computer arguments are sometimes better
than generalized general purpose IPM
method
APM cannot improve strong polynomial
okay
of course
LP so basically you can prove the
condition number or something
then you take a look and then become
this is the condition number
maximum generalize the flow I think this
is approved by
uh which the 13 okay so the I don't know
for very poison go to Facebook systems
so each
hey this is like I think this is
eventually about being naked or whatever
already again some of them says non-ipm
it's not a problem it's not in basically
yeah
uh discard mdp and uh so this is a
important as a discount is fixed mdp I
don't know infrared horizon discount MTP
have a linear programming representation
okay
uh you can prove
Simplex methods policy iteration
Methodist stranded polynomial
but away cannot approve for APM is 20.
okay
uh there was a very very nice extension
where Professor Civic okay
use this technique and you know to to
apply to strategy to reach method right
what's the strategy iteration method
which is the your mdv have a two set of
State one state maximize another state
to try to minimize
you you have a value iteration method
but however nobody know what's the
for that discounted the code of
stochastic attempt based again
okay problems you don't have LP
representation
actually the problem is not to come back
soon
an amazingly
you can prove with discounted As Nice
this kind of fact is fixed
you have a strong opinion
but the original problems
you don't even know whether the
others mpo or not
again another algorithm it's not based
on IPM
so I I just want to know so sometimes I
really want to solve these problems
and I also deterministic mdp we got
discount you don't need to Discount okay
it proves Simplex method is a strong
polynomial
this is a special case on new
programming
I know Simplex method definitely beat
the interior point of migrants in the
worst case
are there other methods that will give
you strongly pollution or this is only
nothing other algorithm also previous
but for this sdp so the natural question
is
so
we will talk about
can you still
can you solve deterministic
zero-sum game
with a strong polynomial time right as
soon as this still open
like a parity game or something
that's open still from nobody can prove
this has belong to and they are at the
same time so
uh it would be nice to crack because
but but I know for if it's not a game
you can solve this one
you can do or not so this is uh some
questions okay so small dimensions of
course you can do this to randomize the
simplex and stuff okay
so
and yeah so this is uh of course okay so
you can do this
again can you mention it okay no
self-concordant battery is strongly
polynomial
basically again
even all the possible barriers if you
consider different the batteries if it
was a barrel
they are they're expensive
so this is also which is the
a lot of an active result
everywhere
ultimate questions
if Markov decision discounts the number
obviously goes to one
uh whether whether you still have a
strong polynomial time of course the
problem can be a solving important
normal time but what about the strong
Department can you prove condition
number of another problem somehow
independent the gamma was
so this is also a potential in the sense
which
okra
so
My Hope Is
if you want to prove whether the
restaurant polynomial diagram for LP
you better proof If the weather for this
come up with this in General on this
complicated
it has a lot of nice structures
deterministic can do it but
General we still don't know how to do it
that's most I want to convey to this
audience okay or call the main cause the
generalize the flow or something mean
cost of flow is but generalize the floor
always
anyway LP remains an open research field
although it has been started for
centuries
somehow
um
if you as a student you can choose
working
LP
or
your charity PPT or something
you decide
thank you questions
yes
does the potential reduction algorithms
that you described previously also fall
into like this follow the our Infinity
Norm neighborhood yeah of the central
past that's an excellent question so as
I said
if you really want to prove condition go
beyond that extensional past coverage
you have to redefine your central paths
or redefine the neighborhood
I don't know maybe potential reduction
maybe give you a different condition
number or something because you go a
little bit further away from the level
so it's potential neighborhood give you
even better
cup like those conditions
so you can use the last number of
piecewise linear function still within
the double set but use much much less
number of nine segments
yeah so that's the mystery and
so all this negative result
for IPM into your point method
is all based on ionized coverage of the
central part
so I think the first things you can do
is
construct to find another example
for better they have a very bad coverage
to see how the potential level set looks
like because it's relatively smooth or
whatever you can't go you can use much
number of nine segments still proof from
one potential jump to a different
potential geography
quiz
thank you
any more questions
all right let's thank you and you again
okay
all right so that concludes the boot
camp just want to do a few quick thank
yous thank you very much to all the
speakers this week uh thank you to The
Institute for all the help over the
weekend to the other organizers so thank
you all
[Applause]
um so yeah